So, you might have noticed that x^2 and
6x^2 may be combined to 7x^2.
And for now, we're going to leave the rest
of the expression as it is. So now, the
next thing I noticed with this expression
is that we need to multiply the quantity
x+2 times 7x^2-1.
This gives us 7x^3-x+14x^2-2, and we'll
leave the rest of the expression the same.
So, our next step is to distribute
the 4 with everything inside the
parenthesis. When we do this, inside the
parenthesis, we get 28x^3-4x+56x^2-8 and
we'll leave the rest of the expression the
same for now. So, our next step is to
distribute the -1 in front of the
parenthesis with everything inside and
combine like terms. This gives us our
solution of -28x^3-56x^2+7x+1.